tomorrow we celebrate our country's
243rd birthday in honor of independence
day we asked 21 year old amanda gorman
the inaugural youth poet laureate of the
united states to write a poem the boston
pops orchestra conducted by keith
lockhart performs one of the most famous
july 4th concerts each year we asked
them to bring music to her composition
believers him for the republic they
performed the original collaboration in
boston symphony hall
12 score and three years ago to be exact
our founders dared to declare the
world's most revolutionary act a pact
sworn for liberty and equality out of
many
was born one people a teeming nation
made of nations at its very foundation
a dream
for life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
today
we gather so that our founders words do
not go diminished but also so that the
work
does not go unfinished for it's not just
in a declaration of independence but the
everyday declaration of its descendants
that make a people equal
it is our right and our wall to remember
these words scratched on a scroll so we
may live them and heal our nation whole
we roll up our sleeves we believe in the
dream in these american stories in the
glory of the struggle for it is from our
struggle that comes our nation's
strength for the lengths that we fight
for what is right is the fullest measure
of our country's might
and while we cannot shake or cast aside
or past
every day
we write
the future
together we sign it together we declare
it we share it for this truth marches on
inside each of us
americans know
one another
by our love
of liberty
when in fact
we are liberated by our love for one
another we understand that a house
divided cannot stand
and so let us make a pact to be the
country that acts
as compassionate
as we are courageous
in the declarations pages we write in
new order for the ages where out of many
we are one bright as a sun and bold as
an eagle a nation of all people by all
people for all people
let's this fourth of july move forward
from five to redeem the dream
as we remember those words forever
ignited that we the people have so long
heard and decided that we are right to
stand but revolutionary when we stand
united
wow thank you all the gorman and the
boston partners if you were in an
auditorium she would get a standing
ovation you should still get a standing
ovation
21 years old whoa
and the good news is we're going to put
that online let me make sure i hit the
chair and not the floor which has
happened before we're going to put that
online so you can because i couldn't
write down fast enough
actually as a result of our introduction
the boston pops has asked amanda to
perform this piece
with them live tomorrow night during the
annual fourth of july uh concert which
is nationally televised oh my gosh i
love her voice i love her delivery
reflections her presence very powerful
the words amanda that she wrote wow
there were i was underlining all over
the place and i love it her appeal for
us to be as compassionate as we are
courageous every day we write the future
she said yep
i like creation indeed yes